and this brings us to our gold medalist
in animation
which is who is glenn harmon with a
second winning film tonight made at
brigham young university
it's titled pajama gladiator
please welcome animator and gold
medalist glenn harmon
glenn
oh what an emotional moment there's only
been a few other moments like this in my
entire life
when i got married when my
two boys i have two boys when they were
born
this is emotional for me i this pro this
project was so difficult and i'm so
grateful to be able to show it on this
screen
and it looks so much better
i uh
it was an incredibly difficult project
as we all know those who have been
involved in film making it's an
incredibly difficult process and and
there are those people who
see us through and
my first thanks are obvious they go to
the faculty and and staff of byu of
brigham young university
uh brent adams who is
the head of it and ryan woodward who
he brings so much life and then kelly
loosely who has been my mentor and and a
man that i look up to greatly
i thank you gentlemen for the the
program that you've put together and so
much quality has come out of that
secondly i want to thank my wife my dear
wife
who uh you know like jed was saying
my wife encouraged me through all those
hard moments so those moments when i
felt like it just wasn't worth it
and i'm very grateful for
her support and
her undying love she's incredible and
this is a tough career to support
and she's there for me
yeah i think so
i also i'm grateful for
there's liz and and blake who are in
here and i want to thank you guys as
well for the work that you've done and
and
and the academy my goodness this has
been an incredible week the opportunity
to meet with and be encouraged by so
many incredible people and we're very
grateful for this honor and and the
encouragement and such a
a big deal
so
thank you very very very much